several hundred thousand dollars I think
is the best way to answer the amount of
cash that we deal with on it on a daily
basis and sometimes though it it can be
up into the millions
when Colorado and Washington legalized
recreational marijuana fronted statewide
shopping sprees followed some 800 people
took a number at this store on day one
alone some waiting in the snow to select
a preferred strain of paw and the
marijuana industry exploded from a 1.5
billion dollar market into a 2.7 billion
dollar one in a year's time
but despite the skyrocketing revenue
growth and a steady march towards
legitimacy as more and more states
legalize marijuana dispensary owners
across the country still face a
troubling problem they have nowhere to
stash all the money because marijuana is
still illegal at the federal level most
banks want nothing to do with it and
that's where companies like blue line
protection group come in they safeguard
the cash and the weed and help
entrepreneurs move from the black market
into the light my name is Ricky Bennett
I'm the vice president of operations and
compliance for blue line protection
group here in Denver Colorado we provide
the security we provide transported
product we hire prior military and/or
law enforcement people what will happen
is is in most cases an armored vehicle
and our security professionals will end
up at the grow or the production
facility where then they will go in and
begin weighing everything is moved to be
a manifest that's controlled by the
state of Colorado and then at that point
the deliveries will move from facility
to facility just like any other
transportation and delivery service
think of it even as UPS or FedEx now
where it sometimes becomes a little bit
tricky is this large amounts of cash
banks are legally required to report any
suspicious or illegal activity to the
feds or face money laundering
some of that changed last year when the
Treasury Department issued guidelines
for banks dealing with marijuana
dispensaries and the DOJ promised not to
prosecute banks working within those
guidelines of course a high level of
uncertainty still hangs over the
marijuana industry because of the
unpredictability of a government it
often says one thing what I'm not going
to be doing is using Justice Department
resources to try to circumvent state
laws on this issue then does another the
Obama administration in congress has
talked about allowing banking under
certain guidelines what we've seen here
in the state of Colorado is that yes
there are a few banks that have stepped
out I think they've done so kind of pro
curiously I still think that the
industry as we move more towards
legitimate banking that you'll still
probably see 30 to 40 percent of the
businesses remain cash Laden and that's
just because of I think the stigma
attached and folks would rather go in
and make their payment rather than using
some sort of system where they're
tracked so we have businesses now that
may pay the IRS with a million five cash
are you going to entrust that to an
employee a younger employee just to put
it in the trunk and move it
we actually transport the money to the
state offices for the Department of
Revenue or for the local office of the
Internal Revenue Service but we provide
a further service we actually stay there
while the money is being counted and
processed by the tax agency and then we
go so far as to return the receipts that
back to our customers for now a handful
of banks and credit unions have started
doing business with dispensaries in
Colorado and Washington and with the
mainstreaming of pot Bennett sees a
bright future for blue line protection
and the marijuana industry as a whole if
the nation moves towards legalization or
other states I do see blue lines roll
expanding fairly dramatically who think
that we can come in and work with the
politicians the business owners and even
the citizens and
let them know that there is a firm that
is tried to think this through from a
business standpoint being the insurer so
that we can move into those states and
assist them right away we think for blue
line the potential in this particular
side of the industry is a target-rich
environment